we've got really good news for you guys
to start off with breaking from the
post-millennial judge rules against
antifa defendants in default Awards Andy
know three hundred thousand dollars in
Damages over Portland attack each
defendant has been ordered to pay and
you know one hundred thousand dollars
I'm gonna be honest with you I don't see
how Andy now collects but maybe I mean
I'm assuming the net worth of these uh
antifa people
probably in the like the negatives so
good luck to Andy but hey it's a
spiritual Victory it is a monetary
Victory and you know it's entirely
possible that many of these antiva
people come from wealthy families they
may have to just write him a check I
hope Andy know takes a nice beautiful
vacation and buys himself a fancy car
the Court ruled in favor of
post-millennial senior editor Andy no on
Monday in his Civil Trial against the
remaining three alleged antiva
defendants that had physically attacked
him in June 2019. defendants Corbin
bellia Madison Lee Allen and samich
Overkill shot Deputy that's the name
were found liable by judge synap
cinaplasai for assault batter and
intentional infliction of emotional
distress each defendant has been ordered
to pay no one hundred thousand dollars
in Damages the virtual trial was held at
the Multnomah County courthouse on
Monday after the three defendants were
found in default for not responding to
the court order to appear at the Civil
jury trial which was held earlier this
month defendants Belia Allen and shot
Deputy that the guy changed his name
apparently to that for that reason were
allegedly involved in the June 29 2019
attack on no in which he was brutally
beaten by a mob of alleged antifa
members they're very careful with their
with their uh fear of litigation while
reporting on an event in Portland Oregon
the attack was received Nation uh the
attack received Nation but attention and
is most commonly referred to as the
milkshake incident Noah was left
severely injured and was admitted to the
hospital after the attack left him with
significant injury to the brain
so we have a I believe Andy knows issued
a statement saying at a hearing today
regarding three defaulted
anti-defendants in my no versus V rose
and antifa at all lawsuit the court
heard evidence about the brutal uh 2019
beating I suffered at a Rose City antifa
Event where I was seriously injured the
court found that I was indeed battered
and assaulted by Madison Denny Lee Allen
Catherine Corbin bellia and samich
Overkill shot Deputy formerly Joseph
Christian Evans the court awarded me 300
000 to be split equally
um among these three attacker attackers
so here's what I want to say as we jump
into the conversation
the reason why these three individuals
did not show up to court and were found
in default they were guilty discernably
guilty visibly guilty in my opinion what
I'm saying is
there's video footage of the attack and
as Andy no tweeted the judge found that
they did commit battery and attack him I
think they knew if they go in they may
even be arrested on on criminal charges
but they actually some of my
understanding is they did show up to the
trial to watch after they defaulted they
then sat and and watched the other
people the other people that were being
uh that were on trial were were found
not liable and so this was pushed by the
left as like oh Andy no loses it's a
it's a failure blah blah blah but now we
have the the award to Andino for three
hundred thousand dollars now I know a
lot of people are saying oh there's
crazy stuff going on someone super
chatted already saying that they like
some cop cars were set on fire in
Asheville we do have that story and so
everyone's very very worried but my
friends we start you off today with a
white pill yo and you know one three
hundred thousand dollars so it's it's
not a foregone conclusion anybody trying
to tell you to give up it's over Trump
can win they're wrong they're completely
wrong all of these super these never
trumpers who keep saying Trump can't win
it they're wrong I got the data to back
that up and we'll get into it but for
the time being there you go everybody
it's a good day huh yeah especially when
it's a victory in basically what I would
deem a hostile courtroom right this is
important hostile territory exactly uh I
think you're right it's hard to see if
they'll actually ever pay out maybe he
has to get in line behind their student
loan debt creditors but there's a chance
and it doesn't matter either way because
they ruled in his favor it would be
crazy to look at the videos of this
attack didn't they mix like concrete
with this milkshake yeah the left claims
they didn't oh and but there are many
reports that they did yeah so it's a
serious assault and if any Court had
ruled any other way we would really know
that that whole city was a lost
territory in my opinion I think it's a
good sign in general too because he was
working with a group a center for
American Liberty that people are growing
a backbone and actually getting you know
involved in litigation and taking things
to the court system rather than just
kind of grousing about it online they
did work with like Simon ativa I love
him and also have been I don't know if
it's the same organization but launched
a lawsuit against the center for
countering digital hate because they
keep targeting people on social media
platforms I just I think that that
generally speaking aside from the stuff
with Andy is just a good sign of things
to come absolutely because people have
to get involved and actually take things
again I had uh these lefties are really
angry they're uh they're they're mad
that Andy no actually won they tried
making that claim as I mentioned earlier
that because the judge ruled in favor of
the other two antifa and you know loses
hahaha yeah but we knew and we said this
the reason these guys skipped is likely
because you know there's there's visible
evidence of them committing this crime
against Andy and they're going to lose
in court so by not showing up they lose
anyway they don't waste their time
concern for that judge and this safety
honestly and I had I I have to wonder
you know when it came to the first jury
the the the the uh the lawyer for antifa
actually said I'm gonna remember all of
you right
and there were concerned from the jury
that they were going to be doxxed and
threatened so uh I'm assuming it's the
the judge ordered this but look the
judge had no choice I bet the judge was
pissed off about it yeah a Portland
judge probably super far left but has no
choice they're in default there's video
they have no way to defend any of their
actions and you know wins yeah I mean
maybe that's good then right like of
course intimidating the jury is bad of
course we want the judge to be safe but
maybe it's a good sign that they were
like we're not even gonna try and fight
this because there's no way out of it
right like there are times that people
need to see that you can push back and
they will cave I think so often because
antifa gets off and sort of easy the
police don't prosecute the same way them
the same way they would other criminals
it's easy to think there's no getting
around them they just get treated
differently and it's good to see uh Andy
know win this I guess I'm I'm wondering
what y'all think is going to happen in
the next year
right we didn't I don't think we've had
a particularly Lively summer this year
it's an off election year so it's pretty
chill but a lot what ends up happening
it's really funny you get these election
years where there's absolute Bedlam and
everyone's like the apocalypse is
happening and then you get an off
election year and everyone's like you
know what maybe I overreact and
everything's totally fine then you get
another election year and it's worse
than it was the previous year so I'm
wondering what do you guys think 2024 is
it going to get nuts uh I heard that
people are want to mask other people up
again so this I think it's covered that
is happening it was this lock this
shutdown stuff that drove people insane
out onto the streets and rioting and
crap so we didn't do it this year we
didn't have the riots let's not do it
again next year I mean I'm in such a
state of Civil Disobedience right now I
have so low interest in wrapping uh
diapers on my face I didn't I got
coveted I killed kovid I feel great now
I don't want to go through this
again so stand with me and let's shut it
down before it begins have a free and
open Society like we're meant to have I
was I was talking about this earlier
today because I I went to Portland this
weekend Portland uh Maine I don't know
about the rest of Maine but Portland
they never got rid of their their uh
covet policies
so they're still in the city when you're
walking down the street you know they
put those banners on street lights they
all say like wear your mask you must
wear your mask and things like that with
cartoon pictures people wearing masks
and uh the crazy story that I told is
the the local casino in the area they've
like won in the whole state well there's
a couple but the one in the area is
called Oxford when you play a table game
these table poker games you're not
supposed to show your cards to anybody
because it gives the players an
advantage because of their coveted
policies still in effect today they lay
the cards down face up in front of
everyone to see so all the players can
see the cards everyone else has giving
the players a massive Edge against the
casino now most people probably don't
care about the casino stuff but I'm just
telling you this was my I cannot believe
that it is 2023 entering 2024 and in
Maine they still have such ridiculous
and extreme coveted lockdown policies in
place the only thing people said to me
is outside of the casino for the most
part everyone ignores the lockdown
measures and I'm surprised the casino
doesn't at least try to get the city to
repeal them or whatever else because it
seems like they would just lose money by
giving everyone else an advantage I'll
just tell you guys we made two grand we
we uh yeah me and Allison my girlfriend
we played 200 bucks each just that was
it and we walked out with over 2000
dollars because like when you can see
the other players cards you can
calculate your odds really easily it's
like imagine if the casino was forced to
allow you to count cards and explain to
you the counting of cards you'd just be
winning at Blackjack all the time that's
basically it's like oh I can see that no
one else has any Aces and I have Ace
King it's like I'm gonna bet really big
look at that I won yeah
I mean in terms of what's going to
happen next year I I feel like I would
want to look at the violent crime
statistics which spiked after kovid and
obviously we had our fun summer of love
an election year we'll put probably put
people on edge if they do try and
enforce some kind of lockdown in the
fall like I've heard rumors are going to
then maybe people will be on edge but
generally I think we are actually
becoming more accustomed to violence
right now we're more used to seeing
violent incidents reported and so in
some ways yes there weren't like major
writings the way there were in 2020 on
the other hand uh we are actually seeing
generally unrest in major cities across
the country you don't actually worry
about the Sandy no uh verdict is that it
will make things worse and the reason is
who is going to enforce that 300 000
against these individuals these are
these are derelict individuals as it is
so Andy like I mentioned they probably
have negative money there's a moral
Victory here but the reason why I fear
there could there's a potential for
escalation is when antifa realize the
courts have no real enforcement
Authority against people who own nothing
there's nothing that can be done these
individuals we would call judgment proof
now don't get me wrong they may actually
be trust fund babies a lot of these far
left extremists come from very wealthy
families so they may be going mom I have
to pay a hundred grand and like just
take it out of one of the accounts I
don't care who cares and then they write
a check and that if that's it good Andy
now gets three thousand dollars help he
buys himself a Tesla or something but I
think there's a strong possibility these
individuals don't own anything they have
no money their net worth is probably in
the range of like a couple hundred
dollars
so what's gonna happen Andy know is
gonna have a sheriff come knock on the
door and be like well we're taking what
you do have and then he's gonna get an
old pair of leather boots or something
he's going to get like an antifa outfit
and how much has he spent on his defense
right now he must have so much money
locked up in legal fees potentially he
could garnish wages
exactly that's what I'm saying and so
other antiva could be like hey look
nothing bad happened they didn't go to
jail even though the judge was like yeah
they did it even if they got arrested
they'd just be said Yes again yup so is
there if you don't pay 100K if they're
just like no screw you don't they get
arrested no jail then no they do not
held for three days we don't have better
prisons anymore
nope now what uh what would happen is
like let's say you got sued and you
didn't pay then the court would be like
they'd go to the sheriff and be like
this person's in default default for a
court ordered payment the sheriff comes
and knocks on the door and says like
we're here to collect belongings and you
can bet on anything so garnish wages in
Garner 2D until it's paid off garnish
wages is is a possibility but that means
these people are getting paid through it
through a an actual like
an actual payroll company or something
it you know that's what I'm saying these
people are like derelict extremists
they're gonna get paid under the table
they're gonna go to some Ally in
Portland and they're gonna say you've
got a payment they're going to go to a
proper business even a McDonald's and
they'll go to the far left extremist
person who works there and be like just
pay me under the table and they're like
you got it maybe not at McDonald's
because there's a lot of red tape there
but there will be like a mom and pop
Cafe and they'll be like don't worry
we'll pay you cash and no one will know
what's happening and then Andy no can't
get into your money thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time